"Escucha.
Escucha lo que dice el escarabajo".
Me pasaba horas y horas escuchando al pequeño escarabajo
que hacía rodar una enorme bola de estiércol,
y mientras lo observaba
oía una variedad de sonidos circundantes.
Aguzando al máximo mis oídos, oía las charlas familiares,
las risas,
el rugido del viento
y hasta el canto de los grillos.
Todos estos sonidos se entrecruzaban
y yo percibía un ritmo entre ellos.
Luego golpeaba mi plato con una cuchara y me batía el pecho con las manitas
tratando de recrear lo que oía.
Desde entonces sigo golpeando los mismos platos,
maracas, tambores, ollas y muchas otras cosas
para llegar a ser baterista y percusionista profesional
(Aplausos)
A medida que iba creciendo, sentía inconscientemente
la imperiosa necesidad de ocultar mi nuevo pasatiempo.
Y aunque no lo decía en voz alta,
sabía que eso no estaba nada bien.
En la mayoría de las ceremonias,
notaba que casi todas las mujeres y las niñas no se mostraban
pero, cuando lo hacían,
aparecían con sus faldas de baile
y movían las caderas,
cantando, batiendo palmas, ululando,
mientras los hombres se encargaban de la parte rítmica.
Años después, logré comprender
el significado de la tradición y de la cultura,
y de lo que se consideraba tabú o no.
En la mayoría de las culturas africanas,
las mujeres tienen prohibido tocar los tambores o hacer percusión
desde hace mucho tiempo.
Creo que este tabú se origina en la creencia psicológica y tradicional
de que la mujer es un ser inferior.
Crecí escuchando a otros decir que el lugar de la mujer está en la cocina
o en la otra habitación.
¿Mm?
(Risas)
Las mujeres fueron objeto de un lavado de cerebro
durante largo tiempo
hasta que fuimos víctimas y empezamos a creerlo nosotras mismas.
Esto, junto con la falta de interés por educar a la mujer,
tuvo una enorme influencia
para que quedara grabado en nuestra mente.
El sonido de un tambor provoca emoción y movimiento.
El tambor es, esencialmente, un instrumento muy sensual.
Una vez, en un festival, un hombre me preguntó
cómo me atrevía a ponerme un tambor entre las piernas.
Me han llegado a tildar de mujer fácil y sucia por tocar un instrumento.
Muchas veces me han cuestionado
por qué elegí tocar el tambor
en lugar de dedicarme al periodismo,
que era lo que estudiaba en la universidad,
actividad que era vista como "más decente".
Una mujer que toca el tambor ¿acaso se ve más débil,
menos femenina,
menos deseable?
En el mejor de los casos, la coloca en un nivel social inferior.
La percusión representa esencialmente el gran legado africano
y su importancia se refleja
en los numerosos aspectos de la tradición africana.
Muchas comunidades incluyen la percusión en sus actividades diarias,
y lo hacen hasta el día de hoy,
desde nacimientos hasta ceremonias de iniciación,
ceremonias de bienvenida,
casamientos e incluso funerales.
Sin embargo, este mismo tambor
está desapareciendo muy rápido del escenario musical,
y el género tradicional está empezando a perder popularidad
muy rápido entre la gente.
Inspirada por la necesidad de preservar esta cultura,
doy clases sobre el significado y la importancia del tambor
a mujeres y niños.
En mi experiencia como maestra de percusión,
noté que había muchísimas mujeres ansiosas por tocar el tambor
pero al mismo tiempo tienen miedo.
Algunas temen el juicio social.
Otras el dolor físico asociado a la ejecución del instrumento.
Les aseguro, no es nada fácil.
Otras, porque sus esposos no están de acuerdo,
y otras porque temen la responsabilidad
de ser representantes de una cultura.
Pienso que todos estos miedos están grabados
en la cautela colectiva de la mujer
porque las atrocidades cometidas contra ella,
especialmente en nuestro continente,
nos recuerdan permanentemente
que si nos apartamos un solo paso del lugar que nos han asignado,
podríamos enfrentar serias consecuencias.
Pues bien, yo uso mi tambor
para contar mi historia personal y la historia de mi gente.
Mis raíces me han formado y mi cultura estará siempre en mí.
Las mujeres también pueden ser guardianas de la cultura.
Hemos nacido para crear vida,
para alimentarla.
No hay dudas de que podemos conservar las tradiciones
de la mejor manera.
Este tambor y yo,
hemos llegado para quedarnos.
(Aplausos)
Sin duda hemos llegado para quedarnos.
Si hay mujeres que han liderado países,
que han ido al espacio,
que han ganado premios Grammy,
entonces las mismas mujeres pueden tocar el tambor
y llegar a un nivel de... ¿10 estrellas?
No, a un nivel de un millón de estrellas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
(Tintineo)
(Sonido de platillos de metal)
(Sonido de maracas)
(Tamborileo)
(Aplausos)